whether you love it hate it I've never
thought about it chances are some nanny
wants to banish presenting the nanny of
the month runners-up Washington State
for making online poker a class C felony
how old is too old for trick-or-treating
and Belleville Illinois for banning
teens from trick-or-treating but there
can be only one nanny of the month and
this time it's San Francisco supervisor
Eric Marr for leading the charge against
Happy Meal toys a measure that bans
McDonald's from offering a free toy in
children's meals the band isn't limited
to Mickey D's and more says it's just
the first step
we intend to look at other issues of
holding restaurants corporations also
our governments accountable for the
health of our children more calls it
food justice and his colleague hopes the
movement spreads to other cities I don't
care how much they say it's San
Francisco they're wacked out there there
are ways around the band
if restaurants cut calorie counts and
add veggies if you have to put a shrek
doll with a package of carrots maybe
that's what you have to do check back
next month for more examples of
busybodies minding your own business you
can market carrots